[Musique]
je m'appelle claudine redon g20 je suis
institutrice depuis trois mois dans une
école maternelle 3 rue saint-luc
c'est le quartier de la goutte d'or
c'est du côté de barbès su allier
[Musique]
c'est un quartier qui m'a surpris la
première fois que je suis arrivé je suis
descendu à barbès et j'ai remonté le
boulevard barbès la rue d'un
charbonnières tout ça est vraiment
j'étais un petit peu affolés par tous
tout ce que je voyais c'était un peu
comme un village un village un peu
étranger dans paris le boulanger le
boucher était arabe
les inscriptions sur les boutiques
étaient faits en arabe
vraiment je me sentais pas tout à fait
chez moi et puis j'ai eu aussi envie de
connaître le quartier est 1 jeudi
j en ai mon ami pour visiter un petit
peu le quartier voir où mes enfants
habitaient voir comment ils passaient
leurs jeudi ou est ce qu il le passait
est ce qu'il faisait dans ce quartier
les
kato oui car sinon je connais pas du
tout cas ce qu'estime kalthoum hyper
calme à l' olympia hier soir les
candidats mme bah merci mademoiselle
c'était un succès pour même que le tome
on l'a vu hier soir on a été dit hier
soir à mener un chanceux que rester une
heure et demie est allé jacky pleurer
qui sont trop promener toute la nuit qui
sont chantés qui sont gentils pleurer
avec leur vie comment qu'il chante i'm
good run et à la place qui s'écoute
transmis le fera en une grande mille
fois et encore les conflits en 2000 à 25
milliards 18000 crème qui vont
considérer ça comme ricky pause de 30
mille francs c'est un peu du fanatisme
aller voir une sente le chanteuse
d'accord ça paie une quarantaine
d'années qu'elle chante la 63 ans je me
mets jamais tenir et ageas et le chant
sont que restait au raid mais avec
presque 1 serbie comme ça mais elle est
beau et il bouge pas un coup c'est pas
comme mature et il bouge pas c'était
complètement là j'ai pleuré pleuré de
joueurs du joie et un joueur qui par
ailleurs est semblable se dire qu'il ya
des gens qui travaillent
mettons ce qui est sûr et certain chez
renault et toutes classes de toutes
catégories qui peuvent se permet d'aller
vers une chanteuse à une place de 30
mille francs
ça fait quand même un peu exagéré on
aurait jamais pu penser agir mma c'est
même assez quand même si ça fait rire
pour un couteau
un show avec beaucoup de sucre annie
qu'est-ce que tu prends aussi s'il vous
plaît alors tu vois je t'ai fait visiter
tout le quartier
tu as vu un peu où habitait mais mes
enfants les enfants qui viennent dans ma
place j'ai vu un peu leur distraction tu
as vu leurs parents tu as vu leurs
frères et soeurs
tu avais tout le quartier quoi qu'est ce
que tu en penses c'est très vivant
oui très discret presque un quartier
tout à fait isolé dans paris dans lui
tout le monde se connaît et c'est tant
mieux ça oui mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il reste très très entre eux on ira
par oui ces termes et oui c'est très
fermé j'ai l'impression
enfin je pense quand même que dans mon
métier j'ai quand même pas mal de
rapports avec marceau et les enfants
viennent dans ma classe les mères
viennent les chercher tout ça à moi
c'est quand même un quartier assez bien
pour cela puisque c'est vers la mairie
c'est au globe si noël aux écoles c'est
nettement moins bien
oui parce que ce sont des enfants qui
viennent de la cerisaie balisés qu'est
ce que c'est que ça la cerisaie sondes
son écart c'est un quartier arabe
quartier oui elles sont des baraques tu
vois il harraga rab naturellement les
enfants ne sont pas toujours très bien
et la façon dont ils sont éveillés leur
milieu familial les difficultés qui se
posent à eux oui est ce qu ils sont
livrés à eux mêmes sans arrêt d'enfants
qu'est ce qu'ils font comme profession
dans ta classe au jésus dit je pars en
tant qu est ce qu ils font surtout des
ouvriers des ouvriers par exemple la
fils de plombier mais pour l'heure
beaucoup de manoeuvres que des oeuvres
mais tu vois moi ce n'est pas tout à
fait pareil ce sont des petits artisans
tu vois oui souvent enfin cette certains
ne travaillent pas du tout enfin cela
c'est à part c'est vraiment
catastrophique mais il y en a certains
ce sont des petits artisans tu vois j'ai
le fils d'un horloger il y en a un autre
qui est tapissier ils ne voient ils
boulanger enfin alors cela évidemment ce
sont un peu reprise et si on peut dire
bien qu'il soit resté quand même dans
leur quartier ils sont quand même un
vocabulaire meilleur dans le fond j'ai
beaucoup moins de difficultés
certainement que toi en banlieue en
particulier pour apprendre à lire parce
qu'ils confondent les sens il parle
arabe chez eux et les sons français sont
différents dons qu'ils éprouvent des
difficultés
évidemment peut-être qu'ils ont
certaines difficultés mais de toute
façon j'ai remarqué que certains
exercices par exemple tout à fait
différent les petits arabes les petits
français
lorsque j'explique quelque chose par
exemple les petits français réagissent
spontanément tout de suite
parfois des fous ils se trompent ils
répondent à côté et enfin tu vois rêver
mais faut tout de suite qu'il parte
alors qu'un arabe
le petit arabe va écouter ce que je dis
vas intériorisé est ce que j'ai dit et
répondra après et souvent répondra très
bien mais lui faut un temps de regarder
trop nul de réflexion vois tu sais pas
du tout la même nature s'est pas du tout
pareil mais il arrive des choses très
très intéressante surtout
[Musique]
g
je
[Musique]
mais fo niemi a pas le cas
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous voyez je suis institutrice depuis
trois mois seulement mais j'ai eu une
formation pédagogique je suis rentrée à
l'école normale
il a enfin j'avais 16 ans à peu près
enfin j'ai fait quatre années à l'école
normale
enfin ma vocation ma vocation je pense
que d'abord c'était peut-être un petit
peu poussé par la famille bien sûr
j'avais j'ai une tante que dans
l'enseignement
pas mal de personnes ma grand mère aussi
était dans l'enseignement mais je crois
aussi que c'est par vocation personnelle
j'aime beaucoup les enfants et je
voulais je voulais est institué j'avais
beaucoup d'admiration pour mes
institutrice mes professeurs
enfin c'était ça que me plaisait je suis
donc rentrée l'école normale j'y ai
passé quatre ans deux années d'abord
pour passer mon bac premier bac deuxième
bagage il faut mater l'aiment et ensuite
j'ai une formation pédagogique de deux
ans au début évidemment j'envisageais
des études supérieures pour enseigner
dans des dents de grande classe enfin je
voulais faire être professeur de lycée g
envisageait de faire mes études en
faculté mais certaines circonstances
matérielles mais on en empêcher et j'ai
finalement j'ai fait deux années de
pédagogie pour les écoles primaires et
les écoles maternelles et maintenant
j'exerce depuis trois mois dans une
école maternelle
[Musique]
j'ai mon petit chat ou un chien chez moi
chez moi je joue c'est long
[Musique]
c'est moche de bois les jeunes
musulmanes jeune richard fisher mais
j'aime pas ça ne gênera pas j'aime me
ressourcer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai découvert beaucoup de choses avec
ma classe de maternelle je ne présumait
pas avant au point de vue affectif par
exemple il n'ya certes un lien qui se
crée entre les enfants et moi je n'avais
absolument pas imaginer avant puis ya
peut-être quelque chose si je n'ai pas
de frère je n'ai pas de soeur enfin j'ai
vécu presque
je suis fille unique et j'ai vécu
presque sans connaître d'enfants tout
petit autour de moi pour moi le monde
des enfants étaient presque inconnu et
là est vraiment il m'a été révélé d'une
façon vraiment étonnante paraît que
c'est un quartier difficile il faut
c'est moi je trouve que ce qui l'est
c'est passionnant au début j'ai
évidemment eu pas mal de de regrets
enfin bien sûr c'était normal le pape
pas continuer mes études j'ai essayé par
moi même de continuer pendant deux ans
mais enfin j'ai eu des difficultés là
aussi c'était la promotion du travail
c'était 11 heures minuit chez moi le
travail dimanche le jeudi à face était
intenable
il y avait deux solutions qui ce qui se
proposait à moi soit de démissionner de
l'école normale ce qui est impossible
puisque je n'avais pas l'argent
nécessaire pour rembourser les études
gratuites et toutes les frais que l'état
avait fait pour moi ou alors ce que j'ai
fait c'est à dire continuer faire deux
années de pédagogie des écoles primaires
et aura plus jamais
regardez moi
vous pas pleurer comme ça à l'école
[Musique]
ouais
voulez-vous voter un petit peu ap la vie
des jeunes à manger ces enfants là mais
ils sont adorables d'abord ils sont
beaux enfin je sais pas moi je les aime
rien qu'en les regardant
on peut tout faire avec des enfants ils
ont une personnalité une façon de vivre
qui n'est pas question du tout changé et
c'est pas ça qu'il faut faire il faut
d'abord essayer de comprendre de vivre
parmi eux
ensuite on voit ce qu'on peut leur
apporter certains ont justement une
certaine un certain recul par rapport à
la société en général et cherche à
cacher tout de suite ils se cachent ils
se renferment mais c'est très rare
surtout à l'école maternelle surtout
lorsqu'ils ont 4 ans les enfants ne
savent pas feindre à cet âge-là ou
feignent très très peu on est surtout
poussé à dire oui s'ils vivent dans une
chambre de tête où se pressent tuerait
les uns sur les autres c'est pas c'est
pour ça que leur mère ne les aime pas
pas forcément mustapha tué beaucoup de
flairer sais tu n'as pas de frais
qu'est ce que tu as alors les serres jeu
des soeurs ils sont comment elles sont
grands avec son petit asiatique grande
commande montre avec tam un cas comme ça
et puis l'autre car ça comme ça voilà
pour le s'appelle c'est raté et irakien
et jeanne mas et badiaa je l avais dit
combien tu en as comme ça ça fait
combien ça ça fait 4 4 soeurs du havre
est aussi la voilà donc tu veux toujours
pas me dire si tu veux faire plus tard
ma mère
comment tu sais que c'est un garçon
pourquoi moi je vois pas ce cas à access
est pas rose dans l'eau et oui ce qu'il
est ce petit garçon vivait aux voix de
ma mère qu'est-ce qu'il fait ton papa il
ya un long travail et qu'est-ce qui fait
son travail
ils font ménage très bien
si loin d'ici son travail oui brisé on
vient sortir deux poulets il n'avait
qu'un homme qu'une aile du pacte c'est
juste moi qui voulais sans expérience au
début on est surtout utile à des enfants
qui finalement n'ont pas tellement
besoin de nous on est surtout utile à
ceux qui sont assez brillant parce que
c'est à eux qu'on essaye de s'accrocher
enfin de spontané mans c'est vers eux
qu'on va mais finalement ce n'est pas
eux ceux qui sont brillants qui savent
s'exprimer ce qui avec qui on a tout de
suite une communication non ce n'est pas
à eux qu'il faut s'adresser quand on
réfléchit quand on voit les autres il
faut voir les autres ce qui reste un
petit peu dans leur coin ce qu'ils ne
disent rien ce qui attend ce qu'ils ont
l'air de s'ennuyer pourquoi ils
s'ennuient pourquoi n'écoute il pas
pourquoi sont-ils bagarreur pourquoi
ont-ils festi et ça il faut essayer de
chercher de voir surtout ceux auxquels
on ne s'était pas intéressé au début
c'est à cela c'est cela qui ont besoin
de nous c'est cela qui ont besoin de
l'institutrice pour essayer de les tirer
de leur torpeur
soit parce qu'ils ont peur qu'ils se
sont recroquevillés sur eux mêmes soit
parce qu'ils ont des problèmes à
l'extérieur familiaux sociaux enfin de
toutes les sortes
c'est cela qu'il faut essayer de tirer
de même le il faut tirer d'eux le
meilleur le maximum de ce qu'on peut
malgré tout le reste essayer d'oublier
fans d'oublier de passer outre de passer
par dessus tout les difficultés et tout
ce qu'ils ont et de tirer de leur
intelligence qui est qui est grande de
tirer le maximum d'eux
moi je suis très heureuse au milieu de
tous mes enfants ils sont adorables je
les aime vraiment beaucoup jeu je crois
en ce que je ce que je fais je ne crois
pas du tout que c'est inutile et pour
l'instant je suis très heureuse donc je
n'envisage pas de faire autre chose pas
du tout je ne sais pas ce que les
circonstances matérielles feront deux
mois par la suite mais pour l'instant je
suis bien comme je suis donc ya pas de
raison pour que je ne continue pas ma
carrière d'institutrice et dans les
maternelles le plus longtemps possible
[Musique]